it's time for roses and Rosie this is
like a wave like the ocean we're talking
about bachelor in paradise
who's speaking of waves I'd like an
ocean of Rose Day to go down my throat
right now discuss this that was great
we had bachelor in paradise episode
number two and it was fabulous and I was
surprised about how good it was
considering how little Chad there was
what so lots of major points to discuss
but first we're going to do a very quick
run-through of the minor plot points
because they might be relevant later
because bachelor and paradise is just
such a saga like The Odyssey I think
there's an ocean in that too so quick
run-through Leah's back and maybe she
had her lips enlarged but maybe she
didn't and then grant and lace hook up
and maybe they had sex but maybe they
didn't and then Vinny and Izzy hook up
and maybe he likes her but maybe he
doesn't because he also kissed Sarah
moving on
so you guys Nick and Amanda were really
heating up but then the entrance of Josh
Murray and it's like there's blood in
the water quick backstory Josh and Nick
were rivals from Andi Dorfman season and
now they're back together on paradise
and they're gonna be going after the
same woman Amanda cheers to you Amanda
you are very good-looking and very cute
and I get it so Josh Murray makes a
surprise entrance and he is just saying
all the right things about all the right
reasons that he's there I want to find
somebody to spend the rest of my life
with this is what we want to hear in
bachelor nation he's there for the right
reasons he just wants to find love he's
been in pain but now he wants to be
better he knows that this process can
work it's proven he's on the journey now
Josh and Amanda bonded over something I
didn't expect them to bond over dog
cancer one thing I did care about their
sailboat date after the dog cancer talk
Josh took Amanda on his date on a
sailboat and it was so romantic and I've
always wanted to go on a date in a
sailboat and part of me thinks well
maybe I'll get kind of choppy maybe I'll
get second maybe I should take Dramamine
beforehand but maybe would be great it
was great for them Cheers
to Josh and Amanda oh also can anyone
tell me where Josh's accent is from
cheers to you I can't figure it out and
he does not have a Wikipedia page D and
E Dorfman tell-all so josh is ex Andi
Dorfman the former Bachelorette wrote a
tell-all about their relationship and
here's the thing Josh spent the whole
episode denying what was said in it not
true at all but all he made me want to
do is read it because Nate called what
was written about him Congrats to than a
little disturbing and what was it I want
to know yeah if you don't want your ex's
book to get publicity don't talk about
it on a national television show watched
by millions and then to add to the drama
Nick confronts Josh because he said that
if Josh wouldn't ask him it out he
really should have come to Nick and
talked about it first man-to-man I want
to tell you that really Nick here's the
thing I really like you but you and
Amanda went on one
Josh stole your girl cheers to healthy
competition I don't have much rose they
left I'm getting nervous but first a
break for a shirtless workout okay I
needed a drink because up next is just
the most deliciously awkward wonderful
terrible relationship guys Evan and
Carly Carly and Evan they could not be
more on different pages about what they
think of each other I've never wanted to
not go on a date more in my life I'm
really excited about tonight I'm not
excited about this right now and it all
culminated in the most Awkward awkward
kiss in the history history it was it
was it was the Cruel Intentions kiss but
so much worse but the string the string
the string of spit the string of spit
and that's pretty much it then Josh and
Amanda have a really normal kiss and the
episode is just about over but but but
here's my question in the teaser last
week we saw Chad making a dramatic
return to the house what is happening
here this week back deep
what am I gonna do so will hurricane
Chad return tomorrow I thinks he will
tenses are hard but it can't be worse
than Carly and Evans kiss let me know
what you guys thought of this episode of
bachelor in paradise I am so excited for
the season it is starting off so strong
be sure to subscribe to ET on YouTube so
that you can follow along with us as we
watch all your favorite shows and follow
me on Twitter if you want because let's
face it I don't have a lot else going on
great time to our jobs now these are so
dangerous